it is my pleasure to talk to you today
about a new culture method for culturing
primary neurons from the adult central
nervous system including the brain and
spinal cord
first i will give a brief overview of
the method
followed by images that indicate the
nature of these cells
including their ability to establish
dendrites and axons
to express adult neuronal markers
to express synaptic markers and form
electrically active neural networks in
culture
lastly i will show you an application
for this method that may advance our
understanding in the arena of neural
repair
culturing neurons have greatly advanced
our understanding of neural development
and over a century after the first
attempts to culture these cells in vitro
we have significantly advanced our
understanding of neurons and their
complex networks
now as we embark towards the next
horizon of repair and regeneration
new in vitro methods are required to
parcel out and understand mechanisms of
regeneration of the adult nervous system
the method described here today is for
research use only and not for
therapeutic or diagnostic use
in this method for culturing viable
adult central nervous system neurons
we have five steps shown in this
schematic
that utilizes extreme gentle mechanical
and enzymatic dissociation
of cns tissue
to successfully tease apart neurons from
their intricately interwoven projections
to other neurons and the neuropull
allowing for successful culturing of
large numbers of adult neurons
in step two the tissue is immersed in a
solution containing enzymes p and enzyme
a
and placed into a very gentle mechanical
dissociator
called the octo dissociator
at 37 degrees the tissue is agitated for
30 minutes without exerting excessive
shear force
thereby contributing to a gradual
dissociation and separation of neural
components
the tissue was then passed through a 70
micron membrane
washed and centrifuged before moving to
the next step
to further remove the contamination of
red blood cells from your viable
cellular fraction
hemolysis is used to remove red blood
cells by suspension of your cell pellet
in red blood cell solution
bdnf is added at 20 nanogram per ml
final concentration
to increase viability of neurons during
this slices step
your mixture is incubated at 4 degrees
celsius for 10 minutes
then centrifuged before moving to the
next step
in summary i have outlined a new method
for culturing viable adult cns neurons
there are five major steps that begin
with tissue harvesting
followed by mild enzymatic and
mechanical dissociation
debris removal
immunolabeling of non-neuronal cells
to obtain a pure neuronal fraction
this process can be achieved within a
few hours
and requires
some equipment
and some level of expertise with cell
culture
different cell types from the cns can be
isolated with this method
including the cortex
the hippocampus
the striatum
the cerebellum and the brain stem
adult primary neurons from these
cultures
form dendrites and axons in culture
and retain their full polarity
where map2 positive compartments
are dendritic in nature
and a
axon that is mapped to negative
defines the axon
from a global perspective around the
world about one billion people suffer
from neurological disorders
that is one in every six individuals
to date there are only 81 fda approved
treatments on the market
if we compare this to a field of cancer
which has been very successful in
translational therapeutic strategies
315 million individuals are affected by
cancer
with 118 fda approved treatments
taking a temporal perspective
about twice as many fda approved
therapies are developed in cancer
compared to neurological disorders from
2015 to 2017
this indicates there remains a great
unmet need to develop effective
therapeutic strategies for diseases of
the nervous system
to date the culture methods that has
been available to us to test various
therapeutic strategies have not been
sufficient
e18 embryonic cortical cultures have
been widely used to understand
mechanisms of regeneration and neural
repair
but remain embryonic in nature
second
adult dorsal root ganglia are sensory
neurons that spontaneously regenerate
throughout adulthood and are unipolar in
nature
these cells have been used to understand
mechanisms associated with motor repair
but success has been limited
a study published in neuron on the right
indicated for the first time the vast
molecular differences of motor neurons
and sensory neurons during regeneration
lastly postnatal day 1 through 7
cortical cultures are phenotypically
different from adult cortical neurons
the development of a purely adult
primary culture system will greatly
enhance our ability to understand neural
injury
neural repair and may lead us towards a
faster discovery avenue for diseases of
the nervous system
in summary most methods for
understanding the molecular mechanisms
of injury and repair
do not represent the adult brain and
spinal cord
screening methodologies may therefore
lead to sub optimal discoveries
using the incorrect model system will
slow down discovery while increasing
time and costs
using this new method for culturing
viable adult neurons will allow us to
effectively understand disorders of the
adult nervous system
and may lead to faster discoveries of
effective treatments for central nervous
system diseases
you